well it's three minutes past seven um
and i'll get started um first off thank
you all so much for
um joining us this evening to talk about
the isaac's yard project
um my name is chris fuller i'm the
economic development officer
for tourist district council and it's
been my great
um pleasure to be developing this work
um in preparation for something called
the leveling up fund
i am coming to you slightly strangely
from
the site itself
and i'll give you a bit of a walk round
um on that one in a minute
um it does feel very strange to be sat
in an abandoned well not abandoned in a
kind of empty garage
uh by night with no one else around
however i have just seen a rabbit
run straight past me um so that does
feel very very strange
right in the heart of biddeford um
i will be very honest uh in that i do
suffer from severe anxiety so
this kind of thing absolutely terrifies
me and
is truly truly horrible but we're really
passionate about making
sure that kind of we're really open and
transparent on this project and that we
really really want to make sure
that this once in a generation
opportunity is maximized
and that we're looking to kind of to not
only get our plans
out to people but to keep listening
the whole way through um the process
and just some boring starter points
and we're all used to them by now so i
will apologize and i'll rattle through
them as quick as possible
um as per the message that hopefully you
all received um at about six o'clock
this evening
we will be um recording this call um
in effect it's another way for us to
make sure that
as many people as possible can be seeing
the site can be hearing about it
and can feel that they can then interact
and start feeding into the process
um we are still relatively reasonably
early days
um so there's a lot of flex in terms of
what we can do
um i will ask that everyone obviously
keeps kind of a positive tone um uh
constructive and sort of supportive um
even when kind of putting forward
disagreements or alternative
perspectives
uh this evening um and that people stay
on mute um unfortunately for everyone
you can't
mute the bird song that i've got in the
background but actually it's beautiful
and it's absolutely lovely
and we will have the the chat room
open and please do contribute your
thoughts
um in there later on there will be kind
of an open
um q a session uh so again
please make sure that and make the most
of that opportunity and i will be as
open and honest as i possibly can be and
the worst i'll do is say
don't know i'll try and come back to you
drop me an email and we'll have that
conversation
in a different way um i'm delighted that
i've been joined by my
economic development team uh this
evening uh who'll be contributing so
we've got
uh hamish cameron who will be uh leading
one of the breakout rooms
he's my economic development project
officer adrian avery
who has the the fun task of leading on
all the tech
um this is a year in
sort of the breakout rooms and all the
kind of things especially
me being tethered in a garage somewhere
um tech has significant
opportunities to go wrong things across
it doesn't uh and then we have
uh cb russell who is our brand new
nature tourism officer
and who'll be doing a lot of work around
sustainability and the key tourism
sector
now so tour phoebe's gonna be monitoring
the chat um
this evening so the way it's gonna um
work this evening we'll try and keep it
to kind of under an hour um
you've got far better things to be doing
than listening to me uh
in a second i'm going to walk through uh
what the leveling up fund
is um which this project is moving
towards rapidly um
then i'm going to go for a quick walk
around the site um
so that people can actually see um the
site
i've posted many a photo about it but i
really don't
feel that those photos fully capture the
opportunity the space
and also how things piece together and
you also
can't capture either bird song or
tranquility
through a photo and that sense of green
uh
and sort of well-being space in the
heart of town is something that's very
important to me
we'll then kind of talk a little bit
through um the
proposals and so the ideas that we want
to be bringing forward
um in two breakout rooms
um before moving to a really open
q a um to end the session so hopefully
that will work and hopefully we'll
manage to make sure that everyone's
questions
uh are answered and that we can take on
board your thinking
um right i'm now gonna see if we can do
the first
joyful piece of technology um
where i will get a little
image up for you um
just gonna double check hamish can you
see that please
yes i can yeah we can see that chris
thank you that's a massive relief
uh hamish did think about messing with
me there by not answering
but thankfully he was kind to me um
so the leveling up fund um in effect
is the government's first significant
effort
to deliver on its leveling up agenda
now that leveling up agenda up till now
has been
reasonably undefined um
this fund is very much looking at a
series of
three core um opportunities one
is around town center regeneration
one is around uh supporting cultural
opportunities
and one is around supporting transport
projects the fund was announced
in the budget in march
however details of the fund weren't
actually
brought forward until the first
half of april now given the fact
that the funding deadline is next friday
that's a very very short period of time
in order to be developing
what as hopefully you'll see are fairly
complex
um proposals so things have had to move
very very fast um but
we're very proud of the the projects
that we've developed
it was originally developed for
something called the future high street
fund
in 2020 where biddeford managed to get
through to
one of the last 101
towns in the country as part of that
funding stream
we were very pleased to get that far but
then absolutely
devastated that we weren't then funded
and we were given
frustratingly glowing feedback by the
ministry of housing communities and
local governments
um frustrating because the feedback was
almost apologetic that they hadn't
funded us
but it did mean that we could build that
feedback and learning
in to our work this time
now all of the proposals that we're
putting forward have come
from detailed community engagement that
was initially
undertaken back in early 2020
working with national experts in the
form of the onion collective
uh if you haven't seen those the
outcomes from that
then those are um available online at
bit
dot l y forward slash knowing biddeford
with both the k of knowing and the b of
biddeford being capital letters
um a
sort of wide-ranging process uh was
undertaken
to get us to looking at what we know
as the isaac's yard um site which is
based in
herds garage um at uh in the heart of
biddeford
um now
the design here was worked up um in
uh june in fact almost exactly a year
ago
and this is an early stage
drawing to sort of capture the sense of
what might be possible
it will probably not end up looking
precisely like this because that's how
these things work i will also make the
point of saying
um that in this sketch it does have
um the space where blanchard's
currently is on mill street removed um
that that's not going to be the case
we're very keen to make sure
that the blanchard's units that we are
looking to include in the project
um with the owner's current support
stays in place partially because on an
environmental perspective we don't want
to release the stored carbon um that
that would
entail but also we know that there are
kind of
solid buildings solid businesses
and interestingly up until the 1960s
we've been informed that there was
actually a walkway through the center of
that unit opening up into
this space something that we're very
keen to explore how
we rekindle
as i said that's um
that's where i start getting technology
uh issues there we go i'm no
technological whiz kid there we go um
i got some very scary error messages
there can everyone
nod your head and becky cat and steve if
you can still see me
phew uh hamish is massively relieved
because that means that he doesn't have
to take over
um
the leveling up fund is not just about
economic gains and we've been really
clear on this project
that this is the truly once in a
generation opportunity to truly
address um or at least take strides to
address some of the underpinning issues
that we all recognize
hold our community back we've made sure
that we're very much
working on delivering yes
economic goals but also community
goals and one of the findings from the
union collective work was around
the need to bridge our community and
provide spaces for everyone to come
together
we're very much focused on ensuring that
we are
environmentally and progressive with
this that actually
biddeford be put on the map um through
this project
and become a destination as a result
with those environmental principles
absolutely front and center
and please please keep an eye open next
week because we have some incredibly
exciting news
um that i'm not allowed to talk about
yet otherwise i'll get in real trouble
but already is putting biddeford uh
on a really exciting plane and social
this space should be a really
sociable um space bringing
people again back together within
biddeford
now enough of me talking i'm gonna go
for a walk
so fingers crossed that my signal
doesn't die because otherwise hamish's
heartbeat
will significantly rise
oh hang on i'm not sure if anyone saw
that
but just underneath that van there is
our rabbit
sorry i'm not going to go and get too
close to him because
that's the last thing he wants um right
this is the rear end
of the herd's garage
now what you might not be able to see
there is just how far back
that space actually goes so at the
moment
i'm facing towards bridging the street
and then gonna swivel around and over
here we have the rear
of mill street so the metal elements
here
are the rear of blanchards
um swinging around again
crabby dicks uh the
mons uh and patch and parrot
now we're keen sort of moving forward
and i've already had dialogue
um with the operators of all those
buildings um less so perhaps
for obvious reasons um about the
potential for those um businesses
to open up um and explore how we can
create real
what's called permeability between the
spaces and create a really nice
inflow with isaac's yard effectively
acting as what we like to call
slow space in the heart of the town um
when you come into biddeford into the
town centre there's nowhere just to
be yes you can stop at a cafe
but you're kind of generally walking
through and
going places rather than just being
within the town
and then okay so there's going to be um
that is currently the rear of silk
lounge
and there's going to be an entrance way
coming through there so you can see the
the fencing there that actually just is
removable fencing that i could walk over
and take away now in fact there's some
harris fencing there
um so that entrance way is already there
and there'll be clear sort of uh
routines through there now this will
initially seem quite dark hopefully my
camera will
adjust i do have the owner's permission
to be here tonight i haven't broken in i
promise
um and i also need to make sure i don't
fall into the pit
because that would be comedy value and
inflation has not kicked in
on you've been framed so i'd still only
get 250 pounds
however and i will say publicly a thanks
to the owner who has been very
supportive uh ever with our efforts
now this space to me
has such enormous potential again
i'm not sure if you can fully grasp this
roof if you walk past
on queen street is absolutely stunning
um and with a bit of love and a bit of
attention
will be a really special feature
and our initial architects were very
keen just to knock this space
down um and start again with a brand new
building
whereas actually again with a sort of
a desire to not release the stored
carbon there's a huge amount of
character
in here um and all of a sudden i hope
you can pick up now
that even on a fairly kind of grayish
evening
there's actually a huge amount of light
in here
then walking through again again making
sure i don't fall over
anything
there's another really sizable part of
the building there
trying to get too many uh registration
plates in um
which again with a bit of love and a bit
of creativity um and again
please watch this space next week when
we talk about um creativity and some of
the people we've got involved
um has huge huge potential
right do
again making sure don't fall down in the
pit
so what's also lovely about this space
is the fact that you you do walk through
different parts within the site
now my favorite part
the roof's pretty good but this bit
is special now if i get away without
falling over in here
i will be absolutely stunned
as you can see it's a little bit
overgrown
at the moment now i know some people on
the call have previously engaged with
a town centre project called the little
green town
um if you haven't then please please do
look up on facebook making biddeford the
little green town
which is a friends of the earth
supported innovation project
um one of about five national friends of
the earth innovation projects
looking at taking over abandoned and
neglected
or unloved spaces in the town centre and
using them
for community growing so there's lots of
fruit
and veg edibles all over the place
and lots and lots of happy bee plants
liz the community gardener is absolutely
in love with this space
and i'm just going to walk through a
second more so you can see
over behind there you've got an entrance
way
or behind there's queen street
um and then we're at the rear currently
of
28 bridges street um
the house will not be included in this
uh
project but this space will be
now i'm actually just gonna go silent
for a few seconds
and hopefully just let people listen
what's wonderful is it's like that
all the time
even when it's the middle of the day and
it's busy out
on bridges streets or on the key the key
is only
a very very short hop away
because of the high walls around the
space
and then because beyond that you've got
the buildings of
queen street bridgeton streets cooper
street
and then sort of mill street that way
you're very very protected from
any noise outside it is an absolutely
stunning piece of tranquility in the
heart of the town
which i will confess up until about
uh 18 months ago i didn't know existed
and if you look on uh google maps and
put it onto um satellite view
you'll see it i've managed to avoid
falling in the pond as well which is a
really good thing
and again this is where i'm going to get
caught in this overgrown but again you
can see how far back
that goes
so the intention for this space is very
much to ensure
that we provide
getting caught on the uh overgrowth
that we provide opportunities for this
to very much
be community managed
throughout the project we want to make
sure that the community really feel a
sense of
ownership and engagement with the space
and that absolutely crucially people
feel proud
of their town and the offer that's
available within isaac's yard
they want to be involved in it they want
to get
engaged with it and they want to spend
time there because
town centres are changing dramatically
we know that the rise in online shopping
means that people don't use towns in the
same way
so it's about how we make sure that our
town which is a local residence
i don't always feel necessarily works
for me or for my children
um so it's about making sure that we
have that shift
right so the key question then is
how do we want to use it
here we go okay so
as i said we're looking at a mix of
opportunities here
now a lot of this project is about
creating
um linkages it's about creating
opportunities that don't currently exist
and what we're talking about um as part
of that
is some co-working space and i put a
um post on the facebook page about that
this evening
um bringing people together um to work
especially those people who've now got
used to working from home
um and that does include people who are
moving down
or people who for example um where
they no longer sort of have offices and
stopping people from having to commute
again with that hefty kind of car impact
we've been working with the north devon
ccg um
a part of the um the nhs and also with
ttvs
local voluntary services to develop
proposals looking at a community hub so
that's bringing together various
charitable
and voluntary sector organizations
to create real linkages one of the
things that frustrates
pretty much everyone i've ever met is
where you have
any kind of issue that you need to
overcome in terms of uh
health and well-being being referred
from one organization to another
organization to another
rather than just going oh bob tina
could you just nip in here a sec so that
we can have this conversation now
rather than you have to have it in three
weeks time and the ambition there is to
create that as a very flexible space as
well
which will allow um bookable spaces
for community events within the garage
one of my favorite elements is the sense
of
creating some really vibrant um street
food small
food and drink units um within that
repurposed garage space which i think
will be a real hit the whole way through
the year um i'm forever hearing and i'm
frustrating myself
hang on there isn't actually anywhere to
go of an evening to just
meet someone for a drink um
a small bite to eat that's what we're
looking to
to do here again a space just to be and
to dwell
um in a nice and calm way both in the
summer
and all year round um
we're then looking to create um 16
residential units including five
affordables
on top of um some of the existing
spaces um the scheme is complicated
um making sure that the numbers add up
even with government input
is going to be challenging however one
of the things about having um
residential offer within the space
is that actually that creates both pride
from those residents
in being within a space and also a sense
of um safety that the spaces never feels
abandoned there's always
uh activity and warmth that comes
through it and we're really excited
by uh again can't talk about it but um
the people that we've got on board next
week
uh who are gonna be helping to drive
that forward and
really making sure that those
residential units are
perfectly pitched for climate emergency
times
and as a starter for um for people to
get onto the ladder
we've then been uh working uh
on plans for a heritage centre
one of the things that i'm acutely aware
of um
is that our town that people aren't
necessarily proud of
now has such an amazing history
that's rich with so many stories to tell
um that we want to really bring that
forward
but equally wants to bring it forward in
a very dynamic way
we want this heritage center to be
somewhere that attracts
um visitors but it's also somewhere that
locals can come back to time and time
again and spend
some time making sure that our young
people in particular
um are really learning about their
history and can be proud
of it and at times challenged by it and
making sure that we're learning from
that
um we want to create as i mentioned
access to the community and garden
and i'm also delighted that we have been
offered funding by something called the
rural
community energy fund to develop
feasibility work on the renewables mix
for the project
we need to make sure that this space
really is driven
by uh renewables and that we're thinking
about
the future of our planet as well as this
space and of the town
so all in all what we're looking at is a
sense of this being um
a starting point starting to get to the
town moving and creating opportunities
and so all that leads to um
next week i had to go to um tourist
issue council's full council
and to confirm their co-funding for the
project
um as was unanimously um agreed to
for the future high street fund in 2020
um
it must be said that this project has
huge amounts of support
from various different organizations
from in terms of uh economic partners
like the
federation of small businesses from
their southwest
business council we have the support of
all the local schools
um in biddeford and petroc
we have environmental organizations from
friends of the earth to
the north devon unesco biosphere reserve
and we have local retailers local
businesses
because this is all about creating the
right kind of change
we are promising announcements in autumn
2021
however last year for the future high
sheet fund we were promised an
announcement in autumn 2020 and it came
out
on boxing day in 2020 which i didn't
particularly classify as autumn
so we'll just keep our fingers crossed
that this time um
that announcement comes as soon as
possible because we really are
determined to get cracking
as soon as we can right um
i'm going to come off of screen share
oh hang up
and then forget to come back to the
actual call there we go
right enough of me talking um
hopefully that's giving people kind of a
sense of the space
itself um i'm now going to hand over to
uh adrian to put us all into breakout
rooms
and so i'm gonna leave one of the rooms
and hamish is gonna lead another one of
the rooms
um we're gonna be in there for 15
minutes um and what i forgot
to do was to uh go to the slide
mentioning what we'd like to be
discussing in those breakout rooms
because i'm aware that i'm well over the
time that i'd allocated um
so what we'd like you to be ideally
talking about
um within those breakout rooms is
are we kind of on the right sort of
lines about some of the things that the
town faces and about creating the right
kind of space within our town
what do you make of the proposals uh in
terms of the components that we're
looking at so
residential food and drink co-working
a cultural heritage centre and the
community hub
how important to you is that how
important to you
is making sure that this project has
really strong environmental
characteristics
and equally the theme of aspiration and
creating opportunities
um i would also like you to have a quick
uh conversation pretty please around the
name
we have been calling the project um and
the site isaac's yard
um it must be said
was not a name that was pushed by the
current site's
owner um although it is his um
surname but it's one that we kind of
felt uh almost
summoned up an image of a kind of
post-industrial space
um having converted then to a cultural
and community
space in a similar way to the likes of
neil's yard um in london
we liked the we liked the name we
thought it caught the right spirits
um but we want to make sure that we're
just double checking that with people
and that people feel that it's on the
right lines
so on that note enough from me adrian
three two one
let's see if this bit works
hey mitch how were your discussions uh
they're very good thank you
um we had some nice uh positive comments
about
the current plan um and the ideas which
was nice to hear
we talked about the heritage uh asset as
well in terms of how we can link
the multiple groups around town into one
space to support
that heritage input and we finished
quite positively on the the
the regeneration benefit of this to the
the wider part of the town to help bring
up
biddeford as a uh a town itself in terms
of just property and how maybe things
like bridgeland street are used
and then the nice thing was there was a
general consensus that the
name isaac's yard fits really well and
actually works quite well with the
heritage part
in terms of this is what it used to be
this was in this family for a long time
and now this is acting as another part
to help build biddeford better
fantastic i mean our discussions were
fairly similar in terms of general
positivity
we had strong support for environmental
principles strong sports
for and creating strong aspirational
routes
the one additional thing that we did end
up getting on to um
was making sure that actually we're not
creating in advance
and anti-social behavior opportunities
and that we really strongly focus
on a design that creates positive flows
through um the town that also tries to
address
issues in jubilee square um and that
actually the space
be made to feel welcoming and supportive
for all rather than any way um in
intimidating or excluding
on that as well to be fair uh steve
brought up in our group
with regards to how that links through
jubilee square and cooper street so
it's nice to lost yeah absolutely and
it's also nice that we are
trying to kind of take strides in that
and that will be a central part of the
design process as well
right now we've got a few minutes left
um effectively
this is open to anyone who
wants to to challenge us to ask a
question to find out more
um it's not your only opportunity to
um it's going to pose these questions um
please feel free and hopefully you've
all got access to the facebook
and page uh bid for biddeford isaac's
yard
please if something kind of crops into
your head later on or you just don't
want to say it kind of
publicly in this spam forum please do
feel free to send us a message
and we will get back to you as soon as
we can
probably tomorrow but as soon as we can
adrian i've just seen that you've posted
in the chat that there was were some
questions
raised oh no just said questions asked
okay
um does anyone want to come off mute and
ask any questions becky
yeah i just was just thinking i'm just
following on for my
little rant about a space to be able to
make music workshops
um it's just in terms of um vehicle
access
uh it for sort of loading things
in and out and getting stuff what what's
what's the sort of
plan for that uh it's gonna be
complicated
is the honest truth um queen street is
not
a particularly wide street um
now actually the way that we are
pitching um the site
i'm not going to go into great detail
but what we're looking at is something
called a 15-minute neighborhood
which has been accepted generally in
planning terms especially kind of in
environmental circles and is now the
main uh planning driver in
uh amsterdam uh paris and barcelona
so it's nice that biddeford is being
kind of linked to those uh cities i'm
sure we can
just create a nice twinning route
between them whereby
actually people living within the town
cent within this space
shouldn't actually need a car um if you
think about kind of the
the site itself has plentiful public
transport
right by the size of it and we're
looking to create uh
working spaces within the site
leisure spaces um we've got the retail
offer
kind of nearby and we're also keen to
investigate things like
uh e-bike rental schemes um
to be able to connect people up for
example to the target trail
to get up to to west point apples oil
for example
um so what we're not looking at doing
becky is creating a large amount of
parking kind of in
the space or um sort of resident
parking we're also focusing very much on
kind of locals so what we don't
necessarily want to see either is
big lorries needing to get into the
space um
that yes that will create complexities
when we come to the construction process
um but there will be kind of um
what i'd call kind of emergency services
access
through kind of the garage space that
i'm guessing would then be appropriate
becky for the kind of vehicle that you'd
be looking to get in if you're running
uh music workshops in here um so what we
don't want to see is kind of
huge amounts of traffic coming through
because we want it to be a safe
pedestrianized
area but equally we recognize that there
will need to be the occasional vehicle
coming through
yeah that's cool um just to follow on
from that
um in terms of the idea that there won't
need to be residents
parking um how likely is it do you think
that
the people who will end up living there
will not have cars
um i would like to think that over the
next couple years we can put in enough
legwork to make sure that actually
people living here don't need to have
cars
that i mentioned e-bikes by also looking
at things like
uh
carpools and shared car facilities to
actually
moving the town towards and the
community
towards less car dependence um
and making sure that there is more here
what i can't say becky of course is that
kind of
everyone who wants to to live here will
be saying no
we don't have a car we don't need a car
um but actually
again this is part of as i mentioned on
one of the earlier slides
that this site being a starting point um
and it being that starting point in
terms of how
how we discuss the need for cars the
need for kind of the
those kinds of kind of uh options
moving forward um so it's
and the process between now
and having a completed site will be a
couple of years um
it will take quite a while to to clear
the sites in the first
instance um
so and that gives us an opportunity to
kind of
invest in that conversation but also
start working with potential people
who will be looking at these um
residential units
yeah that's cool no i i i only ask
because i live in a bit of biddeford
that is
absolutely nightmarish for parking
and it's getting worse and worse and
worse and worse and every time places
are developed there's never any parking
that goes with it and it just gets
worse so yeah completely something
that's kind of on my mind
no rightly so and and sort of that i
used to live in central biddeford as
well and parking was always
a nightmare when i was here um but it's
then about going well we know we've got
the issues with this
so why do so many people need so many
cars
well at the moment for example um 40 of
the
residents of torridge commute out of
district to work
well if you think about the economic
leakage that causes
let alone the pollution impacts why
aren't we looking to support those
people to work
within the district if you don't have to
be driving your car
and sort of say in a kind of a family if
a conventional family both parents have
to to drive to work
you need two cars but if actually um you
can be working within the town centre
then those things are limited if we can
then sort of persuade
some of those two um car households
to be shedding won the cars all of a
sudden you're creating
both space games um and environmental
gains
so it's it's a gradual transition but
it's also about having the relevant
conversations
as a community and that's again
something that we hope this project will
enable us to
have over the next few years cool thanks
a pleasure right i know i promised that
we would try and finish
just before 8 o'clock
does anyone else want to take themselves
off of
mute uh and come up with a question or
make me feel awkward or
um challenge us for anything
apart from the birds i'm currently
hearing nothing
there's a lot of nice birds over here um
in which case
all i can say is a huge thank you to
everyone for giving up um some of your
thursday evening
uh for joining us please do um
keep in touch and make sure that you
keep following the the facebook
page and also the website um and
fingers crossed that the next time we
get to meets will actually
physically be in this space in isaac's
yard
um so on that note thank you so much
have a lovely evening and hopefully
speak to you soon
man thanks bye thank you time everybody
take care